[Music]
recording in progress
any further apologies
thank you
can we move that all
we accept his apology please
counselor all
seconded secondary
sandra thank you all those in favor of
the apology being accepted please say
raise your hands
thank you
um conflicts of interest are there any
conflicts of interest
don't appear to be any conflicts of
interest
confirmation of our previous minutes
um do we have any questions
on our previous minutes please please
raise your hand
no questions or do we have a mover to
accept the minutes of our previous
meeting
councillor williams
and secondary
oh second
thank you all those in favor please say
aye
or raise your hands
thank you
um
carried
um any matters arising from the previous
minutes
none
all right thank you
um
there are no presentations and
deputations at this time so now we go on
to reports um enterprise north
canterbury six monthly financial report
and promotions business plan for the
period ended 31st of december 2021 and
draft statement of intent for the year
ended 30th of june
and welcome to heather from enterprise
north canterbury and your team
you have the floor heather thank you
we're just going to share our screen um
thanks to miles's wonderful
cool support
uh
slide yeah just the entrance increase
like there we are um we uh well uh thank
you for having us and uh we're really
here and pleased to present with two
hours to you our six months report
um you will have received two reports
one
uh for enterprise north canterbury and
one for uh the district promotion uh
reports so um
you have taken those as read so what
what we will do though
is um i'll get janine and myself and
miles
to take you through what we considered
were the key highlights for that six
month period and what we've got planned
for the remaining six months so
um off you go miles all right
so i'll start with the uh highlights the
big successes from the last six months
for business attraction um the big one
of course is aqualance starting um which
will go into
bigger things later on and next year but
i'll get into that for the next six
months
um
and over the last six months uh it's
been a lot of small businesses wanting
help starting up that's been uh themed
since uh code had started lots of people
wanting to start up their own businesses
so
um over the last six months we helped 91
startups one way or another and we can
handle how to say 15
new startups in the district would not
have started without our help
um
30 of those were one-on-one assistance
where we sit down with them and help
them through their planning process
um and i can't read what that says there
because you're covered with faces oh yes
um and
we also are dirty forward new businesses
to the district we promote it through
our newsletter and through our facebook
feed um which we really enjoy doing and
we always hope if it sends a couple of
people to the new business and helps
them get started successfully um that's
a win
um so talking about business distraction
the key projects for the next six months
um
back in with the
wow aqua sports park so aqua land has
proven very successful they got slightly
higher numbers now expecting um during
the summer months they closed on sunday
um and i'm assisting them with the
completion of their investment
prospectus
but regardless of that they're looking
at the wakeboard cable part is the next
stage on the north side of the river um
next summer um
[Music]
sorry what was that
no sorry sorry that was um just a
disturbance from um council officers so
carry on so
um
so but yeah i'm helping helping to look
at speeding up investment opportunities
to get the full water park up and
running as quickly as possible
and also investigating new funding
opportunities i just wrote a letter of
support for them yesterday for a funding
option that they're looking at for some
of the infrastructure for that
um pizza spay trail still still trying
with that we've currently got two
funding applications in
in place
um and we're hoping to hear back from
one soon but we're getting positive
sounds from another so hopefully crop
fingers cross we'll get the money to
actually um improve those trails and get
a high quality
cycle trail all the way up from the
waimakari
to the actually river that would be
lemon awesome
and this is an interesting one the
value-added economic hub um this is
actually in paranoia because that's
where the energy is so when there's
methane conversion from cave valley but
it will result in um
just in the first stage at least 100
jobs most of which we see being filled
with waimakariri residents
um and we're in the process of putting
the business plan on that um attracting
investors and
there's a couple of funding
opportunities towards that that we're
working on as well so those are really
the big shiny projects for the next six
months
oh and yes i'm working on the new enc
website in the invest and the business
support sections
and you can see there's new new enc
brands scattered through this um but
yeah it's just better we're also taking
the opportunity to get rid of the fluff
put more crunch in and
better better design the website from
what it is now we've already got a
really good website but we can do better
and that is business traction short and
sweet
thank you
so um
[Music]
so the highlights were obviously getting
our brand developed and our website
created and getting out there and
showing the world
the new look and feel for uh visit
waimakariri and for the district um so
we had a new marketing strategy
developed which goes over 12 months
and as you as i showed you last time we
met
we went out by magazines newspapers
radio breakfasts and digital via edm's
and social media
so i've delivered the spring campaign
and have come
and in that last six months commenced
the summer which is now finished we've
got a new official visitor guide that is
now out and hopefully you've seen that
it's where it's been distributed widely
um to transport accommodation and around
new zealand so there's 25 000 printed
and we had 40 advertisers in there
um
and for the next six months we're going
to um develop the next marketing
strategy so this time we're the the
first one was an overall look at uh the
district what we have and to get us on
the map and so now we're going to draw
deeper so i'll be able to explain that
to you when we get to that point and
inside that will be a substantial
digital strategy um in line with the
marketing strategy but to look at to
really look at what's out there what
platforms we can use how we can get our
message out stronger better in a
contemporary way but also to to our
absolute target audience as well
i want to get out and work with
businesses more and to create marketable
products
and
and some real good suggested itineraries
for people that's how you use the
district like this is they you know
they've seen what we have and now we can
show them how to how to use it
um i will be coordinating the autumn and
winter um campaign so obviously in the
middle of the getting the autumn
campaign sorted now
and
then also uh with the cycle trail
working with christchurch nz um it's our
or the others to develop a um a product
that will be
a very strong marketable product
and always updating the cycle collateral
and website functionality to showcase
our cycle way so just working with a
designer at the moment to how we can
people can access our information to
make it easier to get around to see what
we've got um and chuggable snipper ball
rise and longer
so you're clipping it before
i'm in charge of the money so that makes
sense um
the event funding has come in two
strings
and i outlined that in the report the
continuation of the waimakariri district
council event funding that we administer
we had 10 applications that we
considered i didn't consider i have an
independent panel of course which is
robin brown claire gifford and christine
wooten
uh considered ten applications they were
eight were successful uh two didn't
qualify
and um they were awarded a total of
eighteen thousand
now i must say a few of those events
haven't gone ahead like the kayak we
boat um
carnival
but they are going to retain some of the
funding in the grant uh because it's
just been postponed and that's the case
for quite a few of those events so we're
not taking the money back
[Music]
we also have a regional
event funding and
money is sitting in our account from
envy
but we only receive the one application
and it was for the light festival
because they wanted to grow it and
unfortunately that hasn't gone ahead
either it's planned for april so
that's the status quo at the moment um
however we are opening the fund again
this month for both funds we run them at
the same time through the same
uh panel and we really need to um
stimulate major events that's what that
regional event funding is and it's a
very um quiet time for events and i
think that's why there's not the same
uptake but they're not going to take
that money back and we're going to
reinfest the council money so we'll
still remain in the pot for event
funding and we have that audited every
year as you know
um what we would like to do is work um
with the event
um venue owners and managers and see if
they can actually come up with some
great ideas around what events
they could host because often um
we have a good handle on who the event
managers are but the venues
like the uh rengar town hall
like main power stadium we've actually
got some really cool events like
laceback function
um even getting them to work together to
look at business events and joan knows
all about that so i'm
planning on the next six months pulling
together doing an audit of the event
venues pulling together those event
owners and talking about a plan going
forward so
that's in the next this coming period
um the information center as i said in
the report i've been working with
council to address the challenging and
changing nature of information services
here in cardboy um and this was raised
at council last week and we're pleased
that the councillors have provided
enc with the direction on the suitable
and cost effective option
so that there is our six month report
uh before i take you through the
statement of intent i probably won't
need to take you through that but um
were there any questions um
regarding the six months reports um of
of the team here in front we can stop
sharing with the screen
we got any hands raised anybody yes
there we go
owl
yeah thanks miles um you mentioned um
the cable wakeboard
project from wow and i'm pretty sure you
said on the north bank um
the regen team now incorporated in the
community board aren't actually aware of
this can you can you tell us what your
what what um
patch of water and
and et cetera et cetera we're talking
about i'm not entirely sure this is what
tony told me he was planning for next
summer if you could keep it across the
line so
it must be on it must be on the south
side on on the lake where the
is it can't be on the north side because
they there's no they have to dead they'd
have to dig a lake
okay
any other questions on the last six
months no everybody seems to be pretty
happy there so um we'll carry on uh with
the intent yeah okay um
our statement of intent that the board
considered and then was obviously on the
board and was approved and draft to be
dispatched to both councils
is very much along the same lines as
last year
um with more emphasis this year on
survive and
thrive
we're going to be facing a very
difficult year for businesses this
financial year
and
you know it's not going to be business
as usual for enc
we are almost in disaster management
again there is a lot of businesses
hemorrhaging
and we are actually putting together a
plan
that our team working with council
community development team
working with msd
there's also a new employment liaison
service that the
msd has set up specifically to manage
businesses that are going to let staff
go because we think that that's a
reality and
to help them
[Music]
either with their deployment or
retention so
msd are going to step in they've just
employed six new uh employment liaison
service offices so
it's going to be a combined effort of a
very strong and well coordinated
community and that for which we're very
grateful to be part of at enterprise
north canterbury so the statement of
intent as i said hasn't changed great
deal our emphasis will be always on
supporting businesses
uh to run the promotion contract to the
best of our ability
the um promotion plan district annual
plan gets put
to the council i think in may
for approval so it goes through our
board
as a draft and then that
district promotion plan for 12 months
comes to the
council for your review
you will also see or you may not see
we're actually going to be not running
workshops in the next 12 months we're
going to pull back
um we've had to cancel every workshop
that we've put up it's a lot of work for
no return and it's just not the right
time we've done this before in the past
in hard times the two things that go in
business is marketing and training those
businesses are concentrating on paying
rent and paying staff so
we know that uh to you know fluff around
the edges
and run workshops um is not the right
time so i've pulled that out of the
statement of intent for next 12 months
so that is really a summary that i put
towards the board
and they support this direction so it is
up to the council to consider that if
they wish to make changes it comes back
to the board and then we um present it
um
we consider any of your changes at that
point
i think that's correct dan isn't it
that's right yeah thank you
so that's the end of your report so
there's any discussion or any comments
or anyone have any questions for heather
and her team
sandra
yes thank you um i just wondered um
we've had discussion in the past about
um
uh
reporting on really the the successes
and failures in a um
in
a data set
um are you keeping tabs on um comings
and goings within the district as far as
businesses um
uh folding and well i mean you gave us
the the startups
have is that a regular report into the
board um because i'm not aware and i
maybe it may have come past me and i've
i've
um i've not recognized it have you are
you putting together some of this data
um for us
we do but
we are we are
not always aware when businesses close
down quite often when they close down
they'll do it quietly so where we find
out about it we do note it and we do
report right
we also um sandra get a annual
prosthetics new zealand stats
that's births and deaths and we'd be
happy to give that to you we do have a
recent one um that we provided to the
board yeah i think the latest one is
2021 so it's not up to date as
knowing which business is closed but it
does give you an idea of the trend of
what's happening
so we can flip that through to you
sandra
yeah well to everybody that would be
great
but do you actually have um
broken down into the towns um
the workforce employed
uh locally
and the
well what what do you have that is
reported
more than annually or is it just that
one
i mean i'm trying to get an
understanding of the economic
development or
downturn
in
in a more specific fashion than um than
we've been talking about well i don't
know that you don't get some of the
stats or that they're they're um they're
gettable and it may be that policy and
strategy at the council
also gets it but i would like to
understand because i don't have a feel
now i mean
i have a feel that things are
turning down a bit
i don't know just how much um locally
that affects the waimakariri district
and i would like some data if that was
possible i'll see how far i can drill
that down for itself
thank you thank you um phillip you have
a question
yes i think
heather miles and janine
um in reading the comments the business
awards are excellent and i was very
disappointed
they didn't proceed
i just wondered some of the feedback
regarding the sustainability category
whether you'll be looking at dealing
with that one differently
sustainability is becoming
quite a serious issue that people are
concerned about
uh what do you mean in terms of dealing
with it just differently
oh you're frozen you're frozen oh there
was a comment uh from other people
uh hang on
we'll wait for you fellas i'll stop the
video and hopefully the sound improves
yes yeah can you
yeah
we'd like to see your face though
phillip
oh sorry can you hear me
yes right um i i'll bring that back
later
i
i appear to be having internet issues
for the first time
oh dear
well we can have your question then
please
oops
we've lost you phillip
from the participants about sustainable
to see your face and see what's
happening
read your lips
yes we
given some of the comments by
participants in the sustainability
category if you're going to look at
doing that differently next year
and yes we are we're looking at getting
uh an expert as a judge we're we're
looking at changing the entire idea for
the next awards and how that works so
we've got a plan in place
right
thank you
that's good i think we got the question
finally thank you phillip are there any
other further questions
that's fine all right i think okay
uh comments any comments
well
so i think we have the recommendation so
um
to receive the report a b
c
n d
so please um do i have a mover for those
to receive reports please
paul moved and dan seconded
thank you
um
any other comments
no
uh write a reply well comment from you
jan yes sorry
you're muted then
i've got you
thank you just to say that i
want to acknowledge the work that
enterprise north canterbury do
in our district
they have mindful support they do an
excellent job
here and you've heard three very
excellent well
two particularly excellent presentations
and of course
heather's
which always
shows just how much work is done
to support our community particularly at
a very difficult time and i just want to
acknowledge
the support that we receive
also the feedback that we gave
the other day around the
eyesight
we're really appreciative of enc taking
on board that end adapting the service
to make sure it's kept here it's really
important for our district uh that that
remains and that was a good conversation
that we informally had as colleagues
about that um and it's just all the
little things that are done like um
coming along to support uh account
myself and jim harland and their deputy
mayor that went along to see sudden
tools and just that regular contact that
you provide
to our businesses at times when they
need it and it's
that support that's shown
makes makes a real difference and just
helps uh those businesses are having
particularly tough times know that
they're supported uh there has been
quite a discussion at the board level
around future opportunities and at a
strategic day just recently and i'm
really encouraged with the plan there
and we'll brief the council on that and
in the fullness of time once that's
developed a bit further um but there is
a there's a lot of good work going on um
you met claire gifford the other day
he's the new uh chair and we've also got
two new board members and grant
edmondson and james flanagan
both from
two significant businesses in this
district which are really starting to
add to the flavor of expertise that we
have at the board table so i just really
want to acknowledge either you and the
team the board and all the work that
goes on to support our district and just
to say have my full support and thanks
for all the work you do
thank you thank you dan um any other
further comments
um paul would any writer reply from you
actually i never got my beginning
replies to start
there you go have a go now
but i'll just echo what dan said so
thank you very much
that's cool um kirsten i think you've
got your hand up you'd like to say
something
off you go
yes thank you madam chair and i
certainly want to commend enc for what
they've been doing through this very
very difficult time i constantly hear
glowing reports about miles um about how
he's supporting businesses out there in
the community and i'm just delighted
that uh we have got this eda that's so
strong
that and so experience that disaster
management even though we don't want to
be um i do however have serious
misgivings about continuing as an
eyesight they're closing all over the
country i've made that position quite
clear all the way through i don't think
kaipu needs an eyesight i don't even
think waimakariri necessarily needs an
eyesight they've become a bit of a thing
of the past um so um unfortunately i
really wish that money could be diverted
into more digital marketing and more
marketing into christchurch for day
marketing um however the council's
spoken and it's always a democracy and
so i just wanted to make my position
quite clear on that because i don't
support that continuing um and however i
do wish you and see all the best and i
really want to see
some of the initiatives that were raised
in the working group
on
district promotion really rolled out
into the district so i'm excited to see
that some of those will be i know
coverts put a bit of a hangover on that
um but i'd love to see more focus on the
rural areas of of waimakariri and oxford
and cast and some of the beautiful
countryside we've got out here rather
than just the town centres we've spent a
lot of time on town centres but one of
our biggest attractions is our natural
beauty and so i'll be really delighted
to see everything from cycle trails to
craft trails coming out this way in the
future and once we're able to travel a
bit more once this
virus has hopefully settled down i
really am excited about the future of
what our district can be in terms of
inviting day visitors from christchurch
thank you kirsten um and i would really
like to
add my little bit as well as
having
a lot to do with heather and her team
with my portfolios and i really
appreciate everything they're doing for
the district and i really appreciate the
fact that they're a separate entity that
can raise additional funds which helps
to
our economic development and to
further
raise funds for for all the um promotion
of our district as well and in
particular hopefully um we can get some
more funding down the track for our
cycleways which connecting through to
haranui that would be wonderful but
thank you very much for your work i know
it's been a very difficult year
um and um all the best for this year and
let's hope that we can have some events
because i know that our stadium
particularly could do us some events um
that would help us
along the way so if we can get something
happening there that would be um
that would be my my thoughts and hopes
for the future for this year
so um having said that if there's no
other further comments i would like to
always in favor of receiving this report
please raise your hands
thank you and thank you so much heather
janine and miles and we'll look forward
to seeing you again soon
great report
right
um there we go so
we'll turn the page
and we go
now to number 5.2
to haytara trust statement of intent for
the year ending 30th of june 2023
and i believe this is greg welcome greg
burns
presentation there we go that's all
yours the floor is yours or the zoom is
yours
um i presume uh that you've all been
diligent counsellors and read the report
so
i'll just consider that has been
done and as you'll see there's just the
number of changes uh some are because we
have uh hoping to have completed work by
the end of this financial year
and the big ones of course for
um
the new year are
focused on getting the karaki beach
sections at the trust owns leased
some income
additional income coming into the trust
sort of helping us towards
some relative independence when it comes
to funding
and of course
um work to ensure that we are well ahead
of
uh getting ourselves a new headquarters
in education research center
and that's
pretty much it the only other one is
talking about some additional fortune
restoration sites now some of you
especially kirsten will know that we've
been doing
quite a bit of work on the four dunes
themselves this is using
native sand binding plants
to
build new dunes along the northern
pegasus bay section of the waimakariri
and we've been very successful with that
i've actually got um
no no it's okay i pushed the mute button
sorry
uh we've got uh
this friday actually i've got two uh
waimakariri district council staff and a
chris city council ranger who
has an area of expertise in four gene
restoration coming out and we're going
to look at another few sites
especially down the waikoku beach end
you're probably all aware
that's the place where the is probably
the most critical when it comes to
coastal protection there's a 90 degree
face on that june and of course a number
of the pine trees have died and are now
falling into
the for june beach area which means that
uh
if we were to get some sort of uh series
of high
tides um some sort of
um
extended sort of uh
wave action it's it's very vulnerable
into the back of the holiday park down
there and we're hoping that we can
actually get a plan in place so that we
can start
um in the new financial year to get that
secured
and that's about all i'm happy to take
any questions that people may have
right
any questions please oh
greg um kristen
yes kyoto greg nice to see you um
wondering have you ever gone and
presented to the youth council at all at
waimakariri i imagine their
environmental group would be quite
interested in what you've been doing
uh no i haven't and as most of you would
be aware i'd be happy to go to the
opening of a paper bag so
um sign me up
oh dear that's nice big there are any
other further
questions or comments for greg
um
[Music]
okay so um
could i please have a move or a mover
poor and a secondary
kirsten um that we accept
the statement of intent
um so um
paul would you like to say something oh
yes it would um
you thanks greg um i actually only hear
any positive things about um you guys
who work down there so um
getting no negatives is a real good
positive for my my side of things so
thank you very much
well done
kirsten any comment from me yes greg
once again just um wonderful that you're
not only producing at great
environmental outcomes but wonderful
community outcomes as well with people
being able to contribute and help um
protect the nature natural environment
so please keep us posted on all your
planting days everything that we we can
do to help spread the word
and if there's any other things that we
can do going forward
your work continues to amaze me not only
do you come to meetings at the drop of a
hat you also seem to produce miraculous
things on the smell of an oily rig so
very very proud of the work that's been
achieved at the trust and and thank you
to all the trust members
for all the hard work they do and how
they help particularly young people uh
get involved in environmental protection
thank you kirsten and dan you'd like to
say something i'll just just echo the um
comments from colleagues and
particularly acknowledge uh council
blecky who's our representative there
he does a lot of work
uh in that space and certainly supports
all the initiatives greg's just one of
those amazing people that we have
uh working for us i've worked with greg
for a number of years now and
the role that he's got at tekahaka
tuatara trust is just a perfect one and
a perfect fit for us uh in all the work
that he does there um that supports our
community the biogen aid which i know
rotary club i'm involved with is
particularly proud of of that
in the name of former colleague of ours
councilor allen and it's something that
we're particularly proud of that and in
the work that go all the way that goes
on there to ensure
that
that area is regenerated
and to go there and to just walk through
is just an absolute um pleasure um
council violence rights a lot of schools
that actually aren't actually quite
aware
of that i was approached by south school
the other day who
senior students are looking to see what
they can do
to assist and do and volunteer and help
in our community and i said well i've
got a perfect fund for you
so i'll connect you greg with those
students who would love to come down and
find out more and see what they can do
but it was one i strung to mind the
other day and particularly the learning
opportunities that they have so if
you're open to those i think that would
be a wonderful opportunity for those
students who are really committed but
thanks again
it's a pleasure to support your
statement of intent and all the work you
do
thank you dan
um yes greg you'd like to say something
you know i just wanted to say um if you
do want to find some negative stuff
when we don't know the lawns down at
pegasus i could find you a number of
neighbours that don't think that we do a
very good job
and currently
as the mayor would know
a number of uh pine speech residents
aren't very happy with the
restoration work down at pines beach so
while you hear a lot of good stuff we do
have some challenges at times
but
we're very lucky in that we have a very
um a solid
set of trustees around the table
and we have an extremely good
management plan which means that
everything is clear and mapped out so
that kind of helps
and i must apologize too
uh one of our trustees rex england is
sitting beside me but he's a bit camera
shy so he didn't want to sit with me
that's why we haven't got it up on the
screen so
he's been
nodding very positively as well
oh that's wonderful thank you
and i write revive football
no you're all good and i'd just like to
um further say thank you for your
wonderful work greg we all appreciate
your passion and what you're doing for
our district so i'll now put to the vote
that we accept the statement of intent
for the trust all those raise your hands
please and favor
again thank you very much everybody
that's um passed carried
now we go to 5.3 greg it's you again for
the six month financial statements
of the trust for the period ended 31st
of december 2021 so you're
you're on the zoom again greg
um thank you
uh well the financial side of it
certainly
jeff has
filled in the bits for the report there
um we're traveling
at the time of the six-month report
very well we certainly have spent a lot
of money uh after this report has
been
uh completed but
i guess like everyone we too um even
though we're tucked out of the way we're
relatively small crew
have been impacted by covert uh we've
managed to keep
the place open
you know whenever we've needed to it's
been a great site for
people to
recreate locally when we've had some
issues last year
uh late last sort of middle of last year
probably the biggest issue that impacted
us the first six months of the financial
year has been
we had intended to replace christina
stett who was our ecology ranger who
moved on
to the department of conservation pretty
quickly so we did some discussions with
waimakariri
around the opportunity of perhaps uh
some of your ranges from silver stream
coming to see if there was a fit there
and we sort of um it looked promising
for a while we thought that might be an
option to
to some full-time work for
one or two of the the rangers down there
and perhaps um bringing some new people
in
uh that wasn't to be
uh as the time as the year went on
uh what we did do instead was we put on
nine staff over the summer period
and this has been
phenomenal as far as
the progress we've managed to make
when christina's left one of them
one of the really important statements i
guess from her accident interview was
about how isolating it can be at times
for
people working
in an area that's
10 and a half kilometers long
you can be in quite a wilderness setting
by yourself for long periods of time i'm
talking days not so bad for old men like
me who don't like people
but it was it turned out to be
phenomenal the amount of work
that we managed to get over that summer
period so while council funds us for
this full-time role of ecology
one of the things the trust did want to
talk with audit and risk and then the
council about was
rather than having someone over the
winter months for that type of work
because it is
fair to say
it's predominantly planting
and paperwork over the and keeping
trails open
the summer is when we do the majority of
our work week and and certainly
supplementing it with a number of people
is really good what was particularly
adventurous to not only the trust but
also the people involved
was we had uh
both zita and emily were third year
ecology students so they put some
practice around the university studies
brianna was from nelson polytechnic
doing the practical component of her
ranger course with nel mack
um
sorry nell pop whatever the hell it's
called sorry i forgot the name nelvex
there late i think
we also had two
young men from conservation volunteers
new zealand who had been trained up and
were looking to go out into the big wide
world we gave them practical experience
over summer
and they've since gone on and got
full-time jobs which we're very happy
about
so
there is a mixed feeling whether the
advantage to us is actually having a
number of people working here rather
than one one person solely out there
trudging through our wetlands and
whatever it may be but that's certainly
food for thought
i think that sounds um
that yeah
that sounds really good to get give
those young ones the um
experience and um and you get a team
going you can achieve so much more than
one person on their own slogging away so
i think that's obviously been great
success so we'll look forward to seeing
how we can progress that i'm sure
any um
comments or any any questions
or discussion
on the financial statements or greg
look you're pretty happy with that i'm
sure
all right could i please have a mover
and a second doctor except this
financial statements
got a secondary paul
right
well um
i think that
thank you greg once again for for your
good work that you're doing and keep up
and we'll look forward to seeing how we
can progress them and look after what
happens uh next year as well so um
paul would you like to say something
i'll just again thank greg thank you
all right anyone else like to comment
right so i'll um
i'd um
i won't need to re write a reply so
put your hands up to accept the
financial statements
thank you
uh for six months
so that's carried
thank you
thank you greg thank you so much for
your wonderful work and we look forward
to cycling away amongst all the lovely
greenery down pegasus like a good way
well thank you
now we go to 5.4
and it's a cyber security
status report
um do we have andy here andy
yes hello andy hello and welcome you're
going to do the presentation on our
cyber
security status report thank you
thank you madam chair
good morning everyone hope you're all
well
and cyber security support is fairly
brief and i'll take it as being read the
two key highlights for me in the report
are
with regards to maintaining our
compliance we're doing well we're either
maintaining or improving against the
benchmark
which is great
news it's sometimes difficult even just
to keep maintaining that level
but we we are improving in certain areas
as well
and the other key takeaway is that our
awareness training is going very well as
well so those that are participating in
our training are actually getting a good
understanding and are actually
understanding the key messages that are
coming through on that
so that's really all i had with regards
to the report itself i do have a short
presentation to take you through a
little bit more detail on the work
program but are there any
quite happy to take questions on the
report itself
um
phillip you'd have a question
hello andy
hopefully you can hear me
um i just wondered have you been doing
any uh
i t work with
elected members
we've had one or two uh spurious looking
emails that we we shouldn't be opening
um
is that something you've been doing or
is that coming from an external party we
don't know of like the russians
maybe
maybe i should be testing you all but no
that's nothing to do with i.t itself
these things just happen every now and
again we get that you know there's peaks
and troughs of activity
um
i don't know how much the russians are
interested in what's going on at
waimakariri district council but you
know you never know
[Laughter]
and so no these are just these are just
um part and parcel of you know daily
activity we see
phil and i know that you've had a couple
and you know well spotted you know you
can see the the the names correct but
the the email certainly spurious um in
terms of its name so
um we just need to keep vigilant and
keep our eye out for these things
when we get those
what should we do with them i've sent
them to you
thinking you'll know what to do with
them um are you the correct person or is
there someone else we should notify
and normally the help desk but what we
can do is then block these gmail
addresses so that they can't they can't
attack anybody else within the community
and but more than happy if you can't get
through the help desk just forward them
on to me and i'll do i'll make sure that
they're blocked as well
thank you phillip thank you
any further questions on that
and you have a presentation now andy i
understand
go for it
can you see that
no
here we go
and he has started
cool
so the main the main thing in the in
cyber security world is when it's going
well nobody sees what's going on and and
that's great but there has been a fair
amount of work that's been going on in
the background with regards to cyber
security
one of the biggest projects we've done
this year was to change our anti-virus
software now that's the software that
sits on all our devices our laptops and
our desktops that protects us against
malicious files
so we've actually recently just changed
from our current product which is a
previous product which is so fast and
we're now using microsoft defender
and
it's given us a lot bigger visibility of
our um devices that are connected to our
network
and but the key thing for me in this one
is that it just doesn't look for files
like sofas did it actually can detect
suspicious behavior as well coming from
devices so
it gives us an awful lot more chance to
intercept and respond
to activity on our network so that has
improved our visibility quite
dramatically
and we're also changing over again to a
microsoft product um to uh allow us to
manage our mobile devices uh
in a more granular and
proactive way
i think the key benefit for this one is
that we can actually create profiles on
devices
so that means you can actually have one
device and have two profiles so it's
probably something in the future once
we've done a bit more testing on it
that we would probably put out to
counsellors so that you have one device
and you can separate your personal stuff
away from work stuff
so we're looking forward and to getting
that up and running over the next few
months
and this also has been a big project for
us and it happens in the background
because we do a lot of this out of ours
and but we have
um
been working on our network to make it
an awful lot more secure
and our last penetration test
highlighted the fact that our
network was not as robust as we would
like it to be
and basically what we've done is we
segment it off so that um
if one part of the network is infected
we can protect all the other parts and
the way we've segmented it at the moment
is based on buildings
so each building itself becomes a
segment on the network so that allows us
to protect the the uh network in an
awful lot more robust way and granular
way as well
um
one of the things that we have been
picked up on is in in recent audits is
around our documentation and our
processes and but one of so one of the
things that we're picking up on is is
how to
do more work around our itdr plan
so we've reviewed that we've started
doing training for the it staff on what
to do in the event of the disaster
recovery
and we're also creating an environment
that allows us to do that testing we
effectively call it an electronic sand
pit so we can we can stand up our
systems in that and and test them
without actually impacting uh on
anybody's use of them
and last but not least we are also
improving our instant response plan and
that's just how we will react if we
actually do have a cyber incident so we
are in the process of setting up
a scenario so that we can do some
desktop simulations to make sure that
our processes and procedures are all in
place and that we
that we can react to these in a in a
fast and appropriate way
so that's
basically it for the presentation
questions
any questions
nobody's got their hand up i think we
must feel pretty happy with our cyber
security
andy so um
could i please have only a mover please
that we accept the status report kirsten
remove a secondary
i'll second it
oh
thank you
um would you like to see something there
kristen it's just for thin think thank
you very very much um this is an area
that's actually critically important to
our business it's going to get more and
more important um so i really appreciate
what you've done andy and reviewing all
this particularly remote working we've
have a lot of trouble with them the
internet is shown by philip earlier um
and we need to make sure that everything
is secure um and i do have a lot of
trouble with separating home and work um
items on computers so that is something
that i'm really would love to hear more
about in the future so thank you for all
the work you do on keeping us safe and
keeping rit systems working correctly
okay thank you
i'd second that are there any further
comments
all those in favor of accepting this
report of andy's please raise your hands
carried thank you very much andy keep up
the great work no problem thank you
thank you
now we're up to oh sandra you're
you're are you all good um number six
portfolio updates
um
now so my report which is um bullet risk
long term and excellence program
um
the annual plan is out for consultation
council controlled organization
enterprise north canterbury is being
audited in march
ktt trust is being audited in april
both relating back to
june 2021
the arts collection is also being
audited in april
um audited statements will probably come
to may orders in this committee and the
excellence program there's nothing to
report so that's all from me
so then we go to customer service
counsellor kirsten
yes thank you
report from marie about customer
services we've had
two teams operating to protect staff as
much as possible in the
customer service area
and that's not possible in kaiapoi but
it is done in rangiora
foot traffic's been actually very low
particularly around euros since the
vaccination pass has been required
most people have been okay about that
there's been a few instances but most of
the time
and the staff have just managed have had
training on how to cope with that we've
got a very new team at rangiora so if
you are passing please say hi to them
introduce yourself um we've got some
wonderful new people in there
um
their new dog registrations preparation
is coming up for first of july so
collecting as many emails and phone
contacts prior so we're hoping to do
more and more of that online
obviously one of the key things people
are going to be interested in is the
district rating revaluation later this
year it's tentatively looking at the 1st
of august 2022 with inflammation
implementation late september
at the moment
limbs have been a little bit low at the
moment but up and down january february
has been a bit quieter
and
we are also participating in the lin's
change of ownership notices module
which means that when a property is sold
the council's notified of change of
ownership at the same time that the
solicitor
applies to change the property title so
that means it's quicker for us to update
the database and change of ownership and
all canterbury councils are actually
involved and subscribed to this service
now
and so that's my report if there's any
questions we're happy to answer them
i think we're all pretty happy with that
thank you kirsten great report
and communications will never isn't here
today so we can't receive his report so
we're going to any further questions
that you would like to ask
kirsten i've just met him chair to note
for the record apologies i couldn't get
into the zoom meeting i was in the
waiting room but i couldn't get through
so i was a little late for the meeting
my apologies no worries no worries we
will get those issues today somehow
that's fine any urgent general business
no that's good well therefore i will
close this audition risk committee
meeting at 10 57 thank you very much for
your
patience and your time and your zooming
well done we survived that one
yes
you